this video is sponsored by Squarespace
start your free trial today at WWC our
space comm / second thought to get 10%
off your first purchase
if you are lucky enough to live in an
area with clear night skies you've
probably looked up in awe of the
staggering scale of the universe you've
probably said something like golly isn't
that super neat or maybe you've had to
take the next hour to talk yourself down
from an existential crisis regardless of
your reaction to the sheer size of the
visible universe it's most likely
prompted you to ask the question are we
alone
remember that existential crisis we're
about to make it a whole lot worse those
thousands of stars you can see on clear
nights taking up the entirety of the sky
are just a fraction of a fraction of a
fraction of a fraction of the whole
universe on the clearest nights we can
see about 2,500 stars each one measuring
fewer than 1,000 light-years from Earth
that's about 1% of the diameter of our
home galaxy the Milky Way this picture
illustrates just how tiny of a portion
of our own galaxy we can see to really
emphasize how huge the universe is take
a look at this animation each light is a
separate galaxy and each of these
galaxies contains roughly 100 to 400
billion stars to put that in a tiny
human perspective that means for every
grain of sand on every Beach sea floor
and swimsuit on earth there are 10,000
stars and it makes you really wonder
with all those stars out there the odds
must be in the favor of some of them
hosting life-supporting planets so where
are all our intergalactic neighbors this
apparent contradiction between the lack
of evidence and the high probability of
extraterrestrial civilizations is the
basis for what's called the Fermi
paradox the paradox consists of several
points first there are billions of stars
in the galaxy that are similar to the
Sun many of which are billions of years
older than Earth second there is a high
probability that some of these stars
will have earth-like planets and if the
earth is typical some might develop
intelligent life third some of these
civilizations might develop interstellar
travel a step the earth is investigating
now and finally even at the slow pace of
currently envisioned interstellar travel
the Milky Way galaxy could be completely
traversed in a few million years so
essentially the Fermi paradox asserts
that we should have some evidence of
alien civilization
by now let's break it down a little
earth is about four and a half billion
years old for the vast majority of that
time the planet was undergoing the long
process of developing more and more
advanced life forms in the short span of
time that modern humans have been in the
picture
we've gone from stone tools to space
stations and were on the brink of true
interplanetary travel now consider a
planet eight billion years old of which
there are surely many in our galaxy if
earth is the standard for the
development of advanced life forms then
an 8 billion year old planet would have
technology three and a half billion
years ahead of our own imagine going
back in time with a smartphone and
showing it to a Neanderthal it would be
completely incomprehensible to him and
that's only a difference measured in
tens of thousands of years a difference
of billions of years would be
unfathomable for even the greatest
modern minds and would surely include
interplanetary and likely intergalactic
travel it's estimated that the entire
Milky Way could be colonized by such an
advanced civilization in under 4 million
years and yet we've never detected even
the smallest shred of evidence for
intelligence elsewhere in the galaxy so
where is everybody
there are many proposed solutions to the
Fermi paradox far too many to discuss in
one video but one solution stands out as
uniquely terrifying we know giant
asteroids have incredible destructive
power as ancient life learned the hard
way but that's nothing compared to the
grim reaper of the cosmos enter
gamma-ray burst or GRB G RVs are
unbelievably powerful beams of gamma
rays released during a supernova or
larger hypernova these intensely focused
beams are known to expel in a few
seconds the amount of energy our Sun
will produce in its entire 10 billion
year lifetime that's an enormous amount
but what's equally impressive is their
range most GRBs are detected at a
distance measured in the billions of
light years some are so powerful but
even at that incredible distance they
can still be seen by the naked eye on a
clear night if one of these cosmic
snipers were to set its sights on a life
harboring planet within a few thousand
light years of its source and the beam
were to strike the planet directly it
would effectively eradicate all life on
the unfortunate world and it likely
wouldn't only affect that one
planet like a laser pointer aimed at a
distant point a GRB becomes less focused
the farther it travels a burst
originating a few thousand light years
away would be over a hundred light years
wide by the time it reached its
unfortunate victim and any neighboring
planets to put it in perspective the
distance from our Sun to the very
furthest reaches of our solar system is
just under two light-years gr bees can
effectively sterilize entire star
systems in minutes since we've been able
to reliably track GRBs we've counted
about one per day occurring somewhere in
the universe of course these all
originate anywhere from millions to
billions of light years away so it's
difficult to determine the true
frequency of gamma-ray bursts but they
have been often enough to cause some to
speculate that they might be a solution
to the Fermi paradox as intelligence
begins to develop elsewhere in the
universe it often gets zapped by these
cosmic assassins preventing any further
development or colonization of other
worlds perhaps life has been unlucky
enough to always be in the wrong
galactic neighborhood at the wrong time
and no civilization has yet escaped the
wrath of gamma-ray bursts others
speculate that perhaps the universe has
been subjected to the majority of these
grv in past millennia and only now are
we beginning to enter a period of
relative safety for organic life we're
still not sure so all we can do for the
moment is hope that some dying star
hasn't set its sights on our solar
system for its grand finale and that
maybe someday humanity can expand far
enough into the void of space to avoid
total extinction gamma-ray bursts are
just one of many proposed solutions to
the Fermi paradox so you can expect
plenty more videos on the subject in the
future if there's a possibility you'd
like to see explored in a future video
let me know in the comments below I'd
like to thank my amazing sponsor
Squarespace for making this video
possible Squarespace is one of the
easiest and sleekest website development
tools out there some of the world's
biggest companies celebrities and even
your favorite youtubers use Squarespace
to create professional sites that are
super simple to maintain I'm actually in
the process of building my own site with
Squarespace and I'll be sure to share
that with you in a future video
Squarespace is offering my viewers 10%
off your first purchase with them just
go to Squarespace comm slash second
thought to sign up and start building
your online presence that
squarespace.com slash second thought to
get started too
if you enjoyed this video make sure to
subscribe if you haven't already follow
second thought on your favorite social
media and let me know what you think
about the Fermi paradox as a whole in
the comments you can watch my other
space related videos by clicking here or
watch all my videos by clicking here
thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next video
[Music]